Texas Paul how are you this morning
oh man I feel like hammered [ __ ] but I'm
right or not so let's get it done yeah
I'm telling you that's right well I I'm
fired up this morning I'm I'm so happy
that Tulsi gabbard finally figured out
that we do not want her in the
Democratic party Gabe Sanchez you
probably feel the same way don't you
uh your your mic isn't working but you
know
yeah well it'll get there so Texas ball
as as Gabe tries to figure out which
Mikey's
you know what you know what I think
happened you know anything happened here
he shot a what was that uh yesterday and
he's probably he's probably switching
his mic there we go hey there yeah there
we go sorry yeah you know what was that
all that jazz do I need Tulsi adios
tells me
if that's what I'm assuming that's what
you're talking about why well Tulsi
gabbard has never been a Democrat as far
as I'm concerned I mean she's also done
one like she was Pro lgbtq and then she
as she was right right against him when
she was done well I mean I mean when
Putin pays your paycheck and Putin is
against you know gay gay people then you
cannot you cannot be for the lgbtq
community I mean this is just not a
thing there there's actually an Alex
Jones clip um I don't know if we'll get
to it today but it shows you exactly
what Tulsi gabbard's doing and exactly
what the Republican party's doing
um we've known for a long time with the
NRA that the Russian um the Russian
apparatus had infiltrated the NRA which
we know the NRA boy if if Republicans
aren't sucking at the teat of the NRA
they're not they're not doing it
correctly and I think Texas Paul that's
a little bit what you're going to talk
about today because really honestly in
Texas it feels like to me and people in
Texas they see Uvaldi
um it's something that can happen in
every single School building in the
state of Texas and they know that fences
and door locks are not going to prevent
this people are even freaking out when
there's just just a little bit of hint
that there's a shooter at a school and
these parents are arriving at these
schools and of course you know they're
terrified for their for their children
and their family members and some of
them have been met with the police and
it's almost just a huge Riot
um just because because they're
terrified because Republicans are
torturing Texans because they just can't
get a handle on what the problem is with
guns and it's guns
well actually you know they they know
what the problem is they know what the
problem is and and I'll disagree with
you a little bit a little bit I love I
love my guns my cabinet back there is
full of them I I've got some of the best
weapons money can buy
I don't carry them around
I don't solve problems with them and
that's the [ __ ] problem in this state
is you've got these [ __ ] [ __ ]
Republican sons of [ __ ] running
around that cannot [ __ ] deal with
reality they cannot [ __ ] deal with
reality so they create these goddamn
narratives I need my guns in case I got
to fight the government you know the
government might be making me do [ __ ] I
don't want to do like read
you know these [ __ ] running
around talking [ __ ] left and right and
create these [ __ ] psycho [ __ ]
narratives that are just [ __ ] [ __ ]
biggest [ __ ] in the world they are
every [ __ ] one of them you see a guy
walking down the street with a [ __ ]
gun on a hip you're looking at a
gigantic [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what
you're looking at as a guy that cannot
[ __ ] deal with reality that is so
goddamn afraid that an immigrant is
going to come over and steal my job at
Walmart that he's [ __ ] walking around
with a goddamn gun on his hip because
you know what he's really afraid of that
he can't run his [ __ ] mouth without
selling somebody telling them shut your
[ __ ] mouth you [ __ ] idiot
that's what he's afraid of
that is the [ __ ] problem that's the
[ __ ] problem it's just [ __ ]
narrative these right-wingers [ __ ]
create around guns and then you got
Maria boutina in the [ __ ] NRA a
goddamn spy for the Russian government
we know it they've told us they met her
with [ __ ] flowers at the goddamn
airport celebrating her how bad she
[ __ ] fist [ __ ] the [ __ ] NRA
and then they gave her a [ __ ]
lifetime job in the Duma of the Russian
government
in our Hancock
God damn uh okay I think I think we're
gonna change it you caught me on a bad
day you caught me on a bad day no no I
got vertigo going on if I fall out of my
chair keep rolling I'll crawl back up in
I'm telling you here's what I'll tell
you here's what I tell you we need to
change we need to change Tuesday from
Texas Paul and taco Tuesday to fire
Tuesday holy oh wow I don't know what
was in that coffee but God damn
well man it just pisses me off dude it
pisses me off I own some of the best
weapons money can buy I will not lie to
you my hunting rifle is made by a
company called Seiko that some [ __ ] is
45 years old and the bolt is still so
[ __ ] tight it is hard to rack that
weapon because it was engineered it was
machined to Perfection when it was made
do I walk around with [ __ ] guns all
the time hell no I carry a gun when I go
hunting I carry a gun when I go out back
buy my pond my custom Pond is also my
shooting Pond by the way very cathartic
place I'm telling you very cathartic
place
why because it's up on a hill my target
is down on the ground so I'm shooting
into the [ __ ] ground so my bullets
aren't going to my [ __ ] neighbor's
property I why because I am my brother's
keeper because I give a [ __ ] about
people
you know I don't need a gun on my hip to
take care of my [ __ ] arguments you
come at me I'll [ __ ] tell you
I'll tell you you won't intimidate me
it's [ __ ] that's who [ __ ] carries
guns [ __ ] that's who carries God we
live in the one of the safest goddamn
countries in the world except for what
gun violence
you take the gun violence off the table
we're the safest [ __ ] country in the
world and where does gun violence occur
in these little [ __ ] neighborhoods
one little dot in a big [ __ ] City
let's talk about Chicago for a second
everybody won't you know we'll get out
of Texas talk about Chicago
oh Chicago's violent Chicago Chicago is
not [ __ ] violent Chicago's the size
of Houston San Antonio and Austin put
together
you take the [ __ ] crime statistics
out of Chicago they're the same as if
you combine Houston San Antonio and
Austin together
and where's the violence in Chicago it's
one [ __ ] neighborhood
that is 90 of the gun violence in
[ __ ] Chicago one neighborhood
the rest of Chicago's Dreamland but
these ignorant [ __ ] bastards around
here walk around they talk about Chicago
like my God you gotta wear a [ __ ]
bulletproof vest you got a cosplay man
you got to have my AR-15 and my
bulletproof pressed and all this
[ __ ] these [ __ ] [ __ ] man
they make me sick
they make me sick these cost Patriot
little bastards like this anyways I'm
sorry yeah like this [ __ ] right
here you know what what the hell do you
need this [ __ ] weapon to order your
Subway sandwich for huh you little
[ __ ] [ __ ] what do you need that for
in public other than to prove to the
entire [ __ ] world that you are a
chicken [ __ ] little bastard that can't
walk out of your [ __ ] house to order
a goddamn Subway sandwich without your
hog legs on you know [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] idiot
you know every gun range I ever go to
has the same [ __ ] rules let me tell
you about guns okay real people real
people that love guns follow rules you
go to a gun range in the state of Texas
anywhere in the state of Texas there's a
[ __ ] rule that everybody has to
follow or the range Master will drag
your ass off the [ __ ] range and you
know what it is
no loaded weapons unless you are on the
firing line
unless you are on the firing line your
weapon cannot be loaded
you break that rule you're [ __ ] gone
but yet this [ __ ] idiot is walking
around Subway [ __ ] sandwiches with
his goddamn hog legs loaded just in case
they ain't got his oat wheat bread
[ __ ]
I I mean I knew you're gonna bring the
fire today because Texas Paul always
brings the fire but I feel like we're
doing the show from the cussing pond at
this point I apologize I apologize
I mean you've got Blake Masters talking
to Madison cawthorne I think it was like
last month I think and he was saying an
armed Society is a polite Society like
this is the this is the mentality of the
Republican Party the only way to fix a
gun problem is to throw more guns at it
not like oh maybe we should try to
course correct the gun problem itself
to have some common sense oh no on guns
see here's here's the reason why they
really don't want uh like red flag laws
[ __ ] like that because it's them that
will be red flagged that's why they
don't want it because it's it's guys
like this [ __ ] that will be red
flagged and he he'll immediately with
guns taken away from him because
immediately a threat that's the problem
here that we have that motherfucker's
mentally ill that's what that is that
[ __ ] is mentally [ __ ] ill
he's got something wrong with him
because as soon as as soon as you try to
present that as an argument the
Republican party will say um no you know
just like whatever two weeks ago they
had the bill that was presented for
mental health services in schools the
Republican Party immediately was like
yeah we're not gonna fund that thing
even though we try to use Mental Illness
as a scapegoat to it to explain or
Justify why gun violence is the way it
is right now again not looking at the
actual thing that's killing people which
is the guns but if you're going to bring
up mental illness and say that's the
actual problem not the guns then you
better double down and back up your
claim by actually funding services and
not stripping them I mean we saw that
the Trump Administration strip those
Services during his time as president
and now Republicans want to say oh well
the real problem guys is mental illness
we have to take care of that it's not
the guns we can't have the government
taking our guns this guy is the same
[ __ ] idiot that would say I need
these guns to stop the government as if
the government doesn't have tanks Jets
[ __ ] rocket launchers if they wanted
to take you out they could take you out
in a matter of seconds they could take
you out before you even knew they were
going to take you out they could take
you out in the middle of the night and
your neighbors would still be wondering
where you were
I want to point something out on this
picture here
okay
I you can't trust a guy carrying a
bazooka in a sandwich shop but you
really cannot trust a guy with blue
jeans that's got velcro pockets on the
back and [ __ ] uh cargo Pockets that
got Velcro on the side this is a guy you
cannot trust forget the [ __ ] bazooka
and the guns just you don't even have to
go past the pants this guy's wearing to
realize he's he's probably you can't
tell me that this [ __ ] right
here doesn't use that bazooka because
it's not probably real it's probably a
prop so you can't tell me that he
doesn't use that thing to just store his
foot long Subs in it I mean that's what
it is I I I guarantee that no maybe no
you know what he does you know what he
does and ladies forgive me for saying
this in the audience forgive me for
saying this but he shoves his pocket
[ __ ] in the end of that [ __ ] bazooka
and just [ __ ] out the [ __ ] out of it
that's what he does with his [ __ ]
cosplay bazooka
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh I didn't I didn't no idea we were
gonna do Pocket [ __ ] content this
morning but I am happy that we are we
are all the way to this guy here of
[ __ ] the Bazooka that he has on his
back
um Texas Paul I I watched the video on
uh
Twitter this morning I believe or
someone had sent it to me I I can't
remember to be honest with you I was
trying to find something I'm so pissed
to Twitter right now I can't see
straight video what what'd they do what
Twitter called me a [ __ ] liar who
they tagged one of my videos and called
me a liar
what I've been pointing out for [ __ ]
ever that the state of Texas has been
throwing away [ __ ] ballots 28 000
ballots they threw out in the [ __ ]
primary you know what a big chunk of
ballots that is in a primary
we're not even talking the election 28
000 ballots they [ __ ] threw out I
made the comment Republicans are
cheating Republicans are taking for
using any excuse to throw out ballots so
dot your eyes and cross your t's and
make sure you're already early early
voting ballots and your mail-in ballots
are perfect they called me a [ __ ]
liar
so I went at them I pulled up all the
[ __ ] articles and I started linking
them to Twitter I said here's my [ __ ]
receipts where's your [ __ ] receipts
call me a [ __ ] liar proof of your
[ __ ] is this the new fact checker thing
that they got going on on Twitter
because I knew they were gonna have no
[ __ ] clue but that [ __ ] is
gonna hear from me
well I I I'm I uh I get your sentiment
there but I want to show you this video
again it's it's on Twitter
um I don't know how they feel about it
Twitter themselves
um about the uh validity of this if they
fact checked it or not but this is a
report from the BBC this happened at a
school in Texas
um so I wanna I wanna get your take on
this it's it's almost two minutes long
but I want to watch the report here then
we can talk about it on the other side
let's watch this
I don't want to learn it
American parents are on edge at a time
of school shootings and lockdowns
in San Antonio Texas parents swarmed to
Jefferson High School after getting
notified of a suspected gun
it turned out to be false but for those
who were there it felt real
at one o'clock I got the text Mom I'm
scared we first heard the sirens wailing
from a distance and that's when like my
heart dropped I was like this is real
this is really real
tensions escalated between parents and
police
one broke a window with a knife and
multiple others were detained a lot of
people are saying that we overreacted
that other parents overreacted we acted
out as parents concerned parents
inside the school anxiety was running
High among students as their shooting
drills became a reality an armed police
entered their classrooms searching for
threats
we put two bookcases in front of the
door so like no one would really come in
I was just like you know what I'm just
missing I look my I love used to the
people that I I'm very close with
Jefferson High School is just 80 miles
from Uvalde that's where 19 young
children and two School teachers were
murdered in May the police have been
criticized for taking over an hour to
confront and kill the gunman Uvalde was
the prime example of the flaws in the
system my confidence in the police is
it's not there
it's not going to be the same especially
if you experience and witnessed
everything we should be safe in a school
we should be feeling safe within our
classroom
so there you have it um the
um the video of Jefferson High
um now this isn't just a problem near
Uvaldi in Texas I'm assuming because of
how Republicans have not only responded
but really the non-response to Uvaldi
um is what is terrifying parents
students and communities in Texas
because that's really the biggest story
here is that there hasn't been a
response from the Republicans in power
um I mean you would think that an event
like Uvaldi and the facts laying bare at
Uvaldi would make politicians who set
policy activate to set policy to protect
students
um to protect teachers administrative
officials police officers
their parents and the communities and
they absolutely have done the exact
opposite and it's because of of guys
like Greg Abbott and bazooka man who
like Texas Paul said wants to uh have
fun with pocket [ __ ] in their guns
because that is the truth they are
derelict in their Duty here now Texas
Paul they're um and Uvaldi there has
been some news
um going on and of course it's been kind
of buried underneath some national news
here but there was a gentleman down
there protesting uh it seemed like 24
hours a day to get some [ __ ] done down
there
um and it seems like that has the ground
has been cracking there and something is
being done now the state officials are
not doing anything but they are doing
something in Uvalde itself tell us about
that
yeah Brett cross I mean I I don't
personally know Brett cross I don't know
what his politics is but I don't have to
I know that man is Texas
you saw those parents down at Jefferson
High School that's Texas
the police showed that they are
[ __ ]
[Music]
into that well we got to go home at
night [ __ ] well then get another [ __ ]
job because sometimes cops don't go home
that's the job
Brett cross sat outside the Unified
the uvale
Consolidated Independent School District
for 12 days let me tell you something
about Uvalde let me tell you something
about Texas okay the Great Planes run
all the way down through Dallas all the
way to just North of San Antonio
and then they stop and the Mexican in
the Mexican desert starts Uvalde is in
the middle of a [ __ ] desert it is dry
it is hot and Brett cross sat out there
for 12 days because
foreign
guys
it's okay
because this boy it was here Garcia
was one of the ones that were murdered
at Uvalde
and those [ __ ]
and the Uvalde School District thought
they were gonna [ __ ] suck Greg
Abbott's [ __ ] and not do a goddamn thing
that's what they thought they were going
to do they were going to swing a little
dick and tell these parents how it is
well I got news for you this is Texas
[ __ ] this is Texas and Brett
cross stood out there for 12 days day
and night eight Pistons [ __ ] outside the
[ __ ] Uvalde School District that said
you will suspend every one of these
[ __ ] officers you will suspend every
member of the Uvalde
police police force
the Uvalde school police force you will
suspend them and you will investigate
this so helping God I will not leave
until you do
and they did it
after 12 days of looking at at Brett
cross every day when they walked in the
door
they did it and the superintendent of
schools
resign uh well he didn't resign he
retired
but yeah he's getting it done and just
like the parents down at Jefferson High
School they're not waiting anymore
they know the police are going to be
[ __ ] chicken [ __ ]
you have a shooting at a school where my
grandkid is you bet your ass I would if
I gotta bust a [ __ ] window to get in
there I'm getting in there and getting
kids out I'm not waiting for these
[ __ ] that got to go home at the
end of the day
to make their decisions [ __ ] that noise
these are my babies you're talking about
no welcome to Texas that's how it works
you don't do the job I will
anyways sorry for being no no no no uh
now everyone knows where the fire and
the heat came from the beginning of the
segment because um I think it's
important not to just to people in Texas
now in Texas they have a unique
situation where they got a governor who
is on the side of the gun and side of
the profit of the gun as opposed to the
safety of the the community
of Texas and the the other unique
situation that they have is in less than
a month they have the opportunity to go
have their voice heard
and today is the last day in Texas that
you have to register to make your voice
heard so my my bet is is that you're
going to tell us you better go get
registered but you don't take for
granted your registration that you think
you have in Texas you better go check
that son of a [ __ ] today if you haven't
already
because they're going to do everything
they can to make sure that they win and
I mean Republicans Greg Abbott did he
did he not show up at a debate last
night is that yeah do I get that right
yeah yeah it you know it he's he's
worthless he's [ __ ] worthless he is I
mean he's a wimp he's worthless he's
useless he's I mean a bill as simple as
hey let's raise the age to the to buy a
assault rifle to 21.
pretty simple it's nothing big it
doesn't violate your rights doesn't deal
to buy a beer in the state of Texas you
must be 21 years old to buy a goddamn
can of beer but you at 18 can go buy a
[ __ ] assault rifle
and and because again they're sucking
that [ __ ] Russian spy NRA [ __ ]
that dumped so much money in this state
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] Greg Abbott
would not even pass that law
that sorry piece of [ __ ]
you know we have a law that says you
have to have a class three license to
have a fully automatic weapon
they've they're fighting making bump
stocks [ __ ] illegal and you know what
a bump stock is it's a spring-loaded
stock it's a spring-loaded stock that
essentially turns your semiotic weapon
into a fully automatic weapon if you
just hold your [ __ ] finger still The
Recoil the weapon hits the spring kicks
back forward and fires again and again
again and again what was used in the Las
Vegas shooting essentially where yeah
where they shot where he shot 500
[ __ ] people
you know people forget this the numbers
on that
500 people from a hotel room what was he
on the 10th or 12th floor
blew out his window and shot I mean it
was well over a hundred yards and
because he had a bump stock on all his
weapons
you can hear listen to the audio on that
and tell me that's a semi-automatic
weapon tell me that you could fire that
many rounds you could squeeze your
friend your [ __ ] finger would lock up
from cramps from trying to fire that a
bump stock all you have to do is hold
your finger still that's it and the gun
will become a fully automatic weapon
your mouth you're modifying your [ __ ]
weapon to make it fully automatic that's
what you're doing
without a class 3 license without the
background checks without everything
else that goes with an FFL and and and
it's it's it's [ __ ] and Greg Greg
Abbott will not do a [ __ ] thing
useful in this state it doesn't matter
what it is it doesn't matter if it's
water it's energy
guns anything he does nothing useful in
this state
he wants to take your rights away he
wants to take your five rights away if
it doesn't have to do with guns I mean
he can't he can't even do the the basic
the basic level of of just being a human
which is even showing up to the funerals
of the Uvaldi victims can't even can't
even show himself can't even show
himself he can't I mean you you know we
we met we briefly mentioned about the
debate that love us last night he didn't
show up which again totally in his
wheelhouse of of doing but even when
they had the previous debate with Beto
he didn't want anyone else there because
he knew the people that were going to
show up were going to be the people that
were pissed that he didn't do anything
about the energy grid he didn't do
anything about the guns he didn't do
anything about Uvaldi he hasn't done
anything like the guy is completely
incompetent from doing his job because
he's paid so much by outside resources
but just the NRA or Russia or whoever
might be this guy doesn't care about
anyone in Texas does not give a flying
[ __ ] about anyone in Texas and you've
seen that through the whole time he's
been Governor anytime there's a problem
he points and blames to someone else or
points and distracts that oh it's
actually this thing and then when it
really comes down to the [ __ ] do your
job aspect of being a governor he's like
ah I would but
um you know what I just won't be there
and the lack of empathy the lack of just
doing the again the basic level of being
a human which is
showing empathy which we know the
Republican party in Fox News and Owen
and all these other [ __ ] don't have
it at all it's just not something that
they have or if they did have it they're
completely stripped away from it by
being indoctrinated by right-wing media
that says don't care about these people
only care about your first and second
amendment and when those things are
violated then you better [ __ ] get
real mad
but if there's anything else that's
about
they don't give a [ __ ] they don't give
one flying [ __ ] and Greg Abbott Rhonda
santis anyone else these are all
symbols of that party and what they
stand for and what they stand for is
nothing but themselves
and it's it it's it I don't know I mean
yeah well I'll tell you that uh Texas
but I don't know if you know this but um
on Facebook we have this guy named fake
Gabe and um fake Abe he usually gets the
wrath for me when he gets in the chat
and he starts [ __ ] talking [ __ ] his
Maga [ __ ] he's a he's a trump copy
machine is what he is now fake Gabe I I
know that you like to
get me riled up and make me make me
undress you like Tim Ryan did JD Vance
but I don't know that you want to [ __ ]
with Texas Paul today I just don't think
you want to but you but you think you
think it's a good idea to get in the
chat and to [ __ ] with Texas Paul today
so I wanna I wanna uh reassure you
because he says here Texas Paul he says
Paul is lying
bump bump sticks
yeah bump sticks do not work that way if
they're sticks you know bump sticks
don't work that way right but but I
think he means bump stocks and he's
calling you a liar just like Twitter did
and Gabe hey Gabe I don't know if you've
been here the whole time
but there's been a lot of heat I don't
know that you want to really [ __ ]
Texas ball this morning again it's
probably not a good idea to call him a
[ __ ] liar when it comes to mump
stocks when you know it's the truth when
I when I sit on the toilet and I take a
[ __ ] and get up and walk away with
what's left in that [ __ ] toilet knows
more about [ __ ] guns than [ __ ]
fake game does let me tell you something
a bump stock is a spring-loaded [ __ ]
stock that when you sit and hold your
weapon if you hold your finger [ __ ]
still The Recoil of the weapon pushes
back
against the spring and the spring pushes
it back forward and because you're
holding your [ __ ] finger still it
fires the weapon again so
it essentially turns your weapon into a
fully automatic weapon all you have to
do is hold your [ __ ] finger still you
lying cut piece of [ __ ]
big game I don't I don't I don't know if
that's the reaction that you were
looking for
um but you you certainly you certainly
got it here today because folks I just
want to reiterate that people are sick
and tired of people like fake game Maga
Republicans Trump copy machines just
absolute [ __ ] Liars shrills for Fox
News oan News Max and the rest of them
they're [ __ ] lies they're Republican
NRA Russian spy lies is what they are
and and and when you shrill for it you
really are because
guys Tim Ryan used a phrase last night
and I tweeted out just the phrase the
exhausted majority
because I truly believe in this country
people are sick and [ __ ] tired of the
trumpism and the lies and the [ __ ]
when people like fake gate know their
[ __ ] Ryan they know they're [ __ ]
lying they know they're bullshitting
they know they love to believe the lie
just because it makes them feel all warm
and cozy inside just like the guy with
the Bazooka who's a weak piece of [ __ ]
who has to have a bazooka strapped
around his shoulder to go order a
[ __ ] a six-inch Italian okay at
Subway it's the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
and the country is sick and tired of the
[ __ ] they're tired of the [ __ ] saying
you can't do anything it's not thing you
do we have to take away people's rights
it's just what we have to do because
because Christianity and God and Jesus
and [ __ ]
and you know who's tired of this [ __ ]
yeah you know who's tired of this [ __ ]
Tim Ryan's side of this [ __ ] because I
guarantee you I watch that you know I'm
Gen X okay I grew up I remember when
Mortal Kombat was released as a console
video game okay I pumped a lot of
quarters in that [ __ ] and I
spent all night last night screaming
fatality I'm telling you Tim Ryan
beat the [ __ ] out of JD Vance I mean he
took him and just held him by the head
and said
and I mean over and over and over again
JD Vance was like this all night
I mean just bracing for what the [ __ ]
Tim Ryan was gonna say next I mean when
Tim Ryan said
Trump told you to your face you are here
to kiss my ass
and you walked out and said I love you
sir I love you I love you sir yeah yeah
I was like fraternity I mean
oh my God
there is nothing people follow strength
people follow strength and last night
they saw [ __ ] weakness against real
strength because Tim Ryan brought
receipts he didn't just come and talk
[ __ ] and say yeah he said let me tell
you why you're a [ __ ] you did this
and I've got video proof [ __ ] I
mean it was beautiful
it was beautiful it was it was The
Branding that the Democrats have been
looking for for a long time and and I
think I think more than anything uh Tim
Ryan proved last night that that that
brand of of liberalism if you want to
call it that uh him fetterman Beto uh
Val demmings she's really oh yeah she is
really slinging that the Democrats are
not [ __ ] around anymore and they are
the party that are going to stand up for
Americans they're going to stand up
against fascism for Americans for their
[ __ ] rights they're not going to put
up with this [ __ ] no more no more
Bourgeois Elite [ __ ] anymore they don't
give a [ __ ] it is time to take off the
gloves and do this fight for democracy
like we know how to do and I believe
that the exhausted majority
and I'm not just talking about people
who who who are of the democratic party
I'm talking about people who consider
themselves socialists Democratic
socialists liberals who consider
themselves moderates Democrats
Independents [ __ ] Republicans are
sick and [ __ ] tired of the Republican
Party telling them what they can believe
what they can't believe what religion
they have to be who they can [ __ ]
love who their [ __ ] neighbors who
their [ __ ] their brothers and their
sisters and their community members can
[ __ ] love what their wives sisters
and their mothers what medical
procedures they can and cannot have what
privacy they can't have with their
[ __ ] doctors they're [ __ ] tired of
it and it doesn't mean that they're
giving up the exhausted majority does
not mean they're giving up it means
we're sick and tired of your [ __ ]
[ __ ] and we're sending you [ __ ]
packing it's enough of the stuff enough
of the [ __ ] enough of the Marjorie
Taylor green Lauren bover Tulsi gabbard
Tucker Carlson Matt gets Jim Jordan
Ron DeSantis Greg Abbott Donald [ __ ]
Trump [ __ ] enough of it we're sick
of it and we're gonna send you packing
and today Texas ball tell us about it
because today is the last day in Texas
to check your [ __ ] registration now
is the time if you're in Texas to ma if
you haven't already go check that [ __ ]
out and make sure if anyone who isn't
registered to vote that and they want to
hear their have their [ __ ] voice
heard they need to go today is the last
day
yeah today's not the last day we're in
the last few hours it is noon here in
the state of Texas a lot of these
offices close you cannot mail it in you
can't do it you got to take your ass
down to the courthouse and get [ __ ]
registered you've got to do it you've
got to be in line don't let them close
the doors on you do you have most of
these places will close down at four
o'clock they will they'll close at four
[ __ ] o'clock
I guarantee you on the last day they
will close down as early as humanly
possible if you let one Gap appear in
that line they will shut those [ __ ]
doors and lock them I guarantee you you
get your ass down and get registered
today I and I will tell you this lose
your [ __ ] job if your job will not
let you walk the [ __ ] off to go vote
lose your [ __ ] job because fascism
believe me you do not want to live under
fascism you don't believe me go take a
look at [ __ ] Hungary go take a look
at where they [ __ ] murdering people
in the goddamn streets you've got these
patrols that run around in [ __ ]
hungry and they pull people out of their
houses because they suspect them of
being gay and they [ __ ] murder them
you know I I I don't know what you don't
understand but this election is the most
important election you have ever had in
your lifetime because the Republicans
are telling you to your [ __ ] face
democracy is over if they win they're
going to hand it to the legislatures
which means democracy is over that means
whoever's in power now will always
declare themselves the winner
and that's it that's [ __ ] it the blue
States will be blue the red States will
be red and that is it and we will and
let me tell you what I tell I told a
pastor this to his face the other day
my daughters
my wife
my grandchildren are not going to lose
the rights that my mother and
grandmother fought to get them
and it isn't a question of whether it's
going to happen because we're going to
keep those rights we're going to keep
our democracy the question is how bad do
I make it for [ __ ] you before you get
the get this through your thick [ __ ]
skull
he said are you threatening to me I said
no I'm promising you you try to take my
democracy or you come in my kid and
[ __ ] it will be the worst and
last day of your [ __ ] life that's the
way it is we do not this is not an
argument
we are keeping our [ __ ] democracy we
are keeping our rights I am not handing
over my children my grandchildren's
rights because some [ __ ] [ __ ]
like Greg Abbott who knows [ __ ] all
about being a doctor has never worked in
an emergency room a day in his life
knows [ __ ] about a DNC or a DNA wants to
listen to some free [ __ ] Pastor who's
not even a real goddamn Christian he's a
[ __ ] corn artist
and they're going to take rights away
from Mike no you are not no you are not
[ __ ] the only debate we're
having is how bad do I have to make life
for [ __ ] you before you get it
through your head that's it that's the
debate we're having
antifa then antifa now and antifa
forever [ __ ] they're cheaper
for [ __ ] ever
I am not putting up with fascism in
Texas Paul is not either Texas Paul
Tuesdays are always fun but today holy
[ __ ] today was fiery I I I'm gonna
challenge you next week can we get can
we get more hotter than we are today I
don't know I don't know if we were or
not you know Texas ball joins us every
Tuesday and what you should do because
Texas Paul you do several shows on your
YouTube channel and you should go see
the heat over there
um everyone in the audience right now
who is listening to my voice go over to
Texas balls YouTube Texas ball tell us
where they can find you to go go watch
the shows and tell us about the shows
that you do every week Wednesday
nights at uh at uh eight o'clock or nine
o'clock Central you will be getting our
pardon me eight o'clock Central you'll
be getting TNT me and Tennessee Brando
get together and do a show where we talk
about these issues Brando's talking
about the hijacking of Christianity uh
we're gonna have a good show tomorrow
and then every Sunday you can come have
coffee with me Sunday Sunday coffee with
Texas Paul I sit down at nine o'clock in
the morning because let's face it the
the the
media news shows that are out there are
crap
they're they're complete crap they don't
talk about real issues they don't talk
about what's really going on or really
affects your life so come have coffee
with me and we'll talk about it I
appreciate you guys and I apologize
want the heat we want the heat we love
the heat here on the Tony Michaels
podcast we do not want want to let up we
do not want to relent we actually want
to make sure we spank fascism and ass
like Tim Ryan did JD Vance last night
and that is that was beautiful that we
should go forward with because it is
enough of this [ __ ] because like you
said this is the most important election
of our democracy's lifetime the one that
is right in front of us less than four
weeks away right now and if you're in
Texas you got less than four hours in
some places to make sure you check your
registration it is vitally important
that you do that so that you have the
opportunity to vote out Fascism and vote
for better O'Rourke and all the way down
the ballot for Democrats and
pro-democracy candidates in Texas it is
super important because like we said
antifa then antifa now and antifa
forever [ __ ] and today's the deadline
in Florida too today's the deadline in
Florida well I don't care what state
you're in I don't care what county
you're in what district you're in I
don't give a [ __ ] go check your
registration today just pretend today is
the last last day everywhere and go
check your registration but don't just
do that don't just stop there make sure
your friends your family check the
registration if they're not registered
get encourage them get [ __ ] give them
a ride buy a bus ticket pay for an Uber
to get them down to an election office
and register to vote because our
democracy's life depends on it this is
the most important election and Texas
Paul as soon as this one's over as soon
as this election's over and it's counted
and Democrats have piled mountains and
mountains and mountains on top of these
[ __ ] fascists the next election will
be the most important election Barn
democracy's lifetime we cannot relent we
cannot stop fighting they they are not
going to crawl back underneath their
rocks anytime soon they are out there
proud and they are they are ready they
are ready to take over our democracy and
kill it so we have we have to stand and
protect it and how you do that is to
lean into democracy Texas Paul as always
thanks for joining us my friend I can't
wait I can't wait for your show tomorrow
I'll be watching
Brando everyone
don't forget to watch Wednesday TNT him
and Texas Brando and also Sunday go get
some coffee with Texas Paul Texas fall
with the heat today everyone stick
around
what's that Texas ball you got something
Tony and Gabe best podcast available
right now Bar None you guys are killing
it love it love you guys let me tell you
something when you're on it is the
hottest podcast on the [ __ ] internet
ever in the history of ever ever so
everyone again go follow Texas fall on
YouTube go watch Sunday coffee and
tomorrow TNT with him and Tennessee
Brandon and everyone stick around don't
go anywhere I'm going to show you these
Tim Ryan Clips right after this break